edwin royal was born in mexico he and
his family have a love
for baking this passion has been passed
on from generation to generation and as
sally jaramillo reports as a family
they've made their american dream come
true in las vegas
we come here trying to do
something better for the family we are
from mexico
and actually we are
a big family together as a family they
had one dream
to open up a bakery when we come here to
the u.s
we work at the supermarkets in the same
you know the bakery
and we we have the opportunity to make
this business and we are
we are here arroyo says together they
wanted to do something for the las vegas
community
we want to do something better for our
people like
like you know something like just
you can buy it at the stream i wanted to
give some
of something better better quality uh
[Music]
everything we're trying to do everything
for
the people cakes custom cakes
jellies and everything and that's when
vegas bakery became a reality
when the people just come here just it's
just surprised
and here at vegas bakery bringing
diversity to the valley
is their number one priority we have
something
for each place like like italy el
salvador
we're trying to do stuff for
all the places we have many breads right
here
we have like the famous borachitos
we have a lot of cookies
the famous conscious too we have like
like
mini cheesecakes right here we have a
macaroons
we have cannolis and the one thing you
must try
the famous four in one cake delicious
cake
uh chocolate cake cheesecake and flan
i like the variety and i like to try new
things
and i always like the
quality of the products arroyo's advice
to all those looking to pursue their
dreams
if you want something you can do it hard
work paid off reporting
sally jaramillo oh that looks
delicious vegas bakery has two locations
the first one between north jones
boulevard and lake mead boulevard and
the second between lake mead
and civic center brian